give you the names of the ball
everyone's already inside
[Music]
an explosion rocked the city today
20,000 pounds for the names of the
Bombers that's not how we do things
hello mr. hannassey
is here again that's five days in a row
now listen what daughter was killed in
the bombing mr. Hennessy please find out
the names of the Bombers I work for the
government not terrorists is new to
offer them I don't know the bombers are
don't believe you it's him you will tell
me the names of the Palmers you tell me
I'm Tuesday it screams there they are
where's me let me Special Forces home it
says this town why don't you down here
me just wants you to know it got you
what is going on six I know who Laura's
daughter leiana every school somebody
say a prayer but to kill me
dad a pastor city looking for me
then you got a limb he burns oh man
running circles around a lot of us the
hair is every step of the way open it up
you have no idea who you're dealing with
their product because they call it
controls last play a prayer book yes I
do do you
you